yes this is the veal family's epic ice
cream this is huge this is taller than a
lot of houses incredible we stopped by
the Veals family house in Indianapolis
to meet ice tree builder Chad veal to
find out more on the third-generation
extra builder so start off my grandpa
went down to my dad of his brothers and
now to me and my cousins he's truly
harnessing the harshness of the elements
and turning it into something beautiful
so the ice tree is normally right there
and the front yard doesn't even see this
no tree it's because it's not a tree
it's a pile of wood that we make well
ice tree sounds cooler than a nice pile
of wood but how exactly do they build
this sky-high glacier they start off by
making a frame out of scrap timber and
tree branches and then when the weather
drops below 30 degrees Fahrenheit or
minus 1 degrees Celsius they attach
garden hoses which they then turn on and
let nature do the rest most of the
construction just branches so you want
to find branches that are kind of bushy
like this one has lots of sois branches
coming off of it and so that gives you a
lot of service area for water to catch
on and they'll blossom icicles and pile
off the ice this ice tree gets its
characteristic shape because of the way
that icicles are formed high school's
form when it's below freezing out and
then the Sun comes out and it warms up
the ice just enough or a little bit of
water drips all the way down to the end
and then because of surface tension the
water's held at the tip of the icicle
and now that droplet dissipates its heat
out into the atmosphere causing it to
freeze and this perfect balance between
the Sun melting it and it freezing at
the tip is what causes the ice cold to
grow
to make it even prettier they've thrown
on powdered dyes which get frozen into
the structure so we put castrated food
coloring in the bottom right here and
then when the water comes out right here
it brings the food coloring with it and
so when that freezes you get the colors
on the tree you just get all sorts that
people come in to check it out one time
someone came in July to come look at it
it's like we don't we're gonna put it in
a box we don't have it enjoy it freezer
it's not gonna be here building the tree
is a family experience everyone gets
involved my daddy's brother in my aunt
her daughter and the rest of the family
come along and help out thanks guys
from a giant ice tree to a glowing sea